but sound of Freedom was was meaning we
need movies like that even Groundhog Day
right Groundhog Day seems simple comedy
but it's so so powerful so right yeah
like you walk away from you want to be a
better person yeah but it's fun you know
it's like interesting it's an
interesting idea yeah
the system has gutted out the the place
where people can play and take risks
they've gone to tent poles they've
that's where they can invest the money
that's the way that they know how to
make the cinemas work and that's the way
they keep the competition out so nobody
can get in and and play with risky
storytelling and uh the angel model has
opened that door again yep I think that
door is wide open now yeah is it because
you guys now have contacts I'm still a
little foggy on the whole process so you
I mean I know you have a hundred
thousand investors that pick the thing
they'll fund the thing and then we can
predict the Rotten Tomatoes audience
score based off the skills oh nice